[Music]
helen is an accomplished
author she is a senior faculty member
she's a program head she's just one of
the most fiercest
advocates for students that i have
witnessed on mit campus
she's incredibly dedicated to
fighting for what is just and what is
right and what's important
to students and what's valuable in their
lives and
she doesn't give up easily on that fight
and it's really truly inspirational to
see it
she lifts us for by being a truth-teller
that's who helen is and she
helps support us and create conditions
for our students
to name and tell their own truth
and we so much need that in our society
and in our places
her smile is like a hug
um and whatever is making you kind of
hike up your shoulders maybe by the end
of the day you know those
those tensions we tend to feel and
before we know it our shoulders are up
here
um it it just kind of slides into the
background
and the tension leaves just
in her presence she's a writer
so she's very good at
presenting her case extremely eloquently
and very thoughtfully
and it makes it impossible to deny the
truth of what she's saying
she just exudes the kind of kindness and
caring
that enables so many people regardless
of what their job title is
um to feel like we we all belong
in all of the spaces at mit
[Music]
you